quel est le rôle de la maison royale
d'arabie saoudite dans l'assassinât du
journaliste saoudien jamal racho guy
c'est la question à laquelle a voulu
répondre ce rapport l'administration
biden a décidé de déclassifier les
conclusions de l'enquêté des services
secrets américains dans un souci de
transparence selon la maison blanche
le prince héritier d'arabie saoudite
mohamed ben salman à valider une
opération à istanbul en turquie pour
capturer ou tuer le journaliste saoudien
jamal rachid diamal racho guide décédé
en octobre 2018 dans le consulat de
l'arabie saoudite à istanbul
le journaliste et critique envers le
pouvoir saoudien avait exilé aux états
unis en juin 2017 et était devenu
chroniqueur pour le journal the
washington post le rapport révèle
également l'implication dans son
commando d'une vingtaine de personnes
dont l'ancien directeur adjoint du
renseignement saoudien al asiri blanchi
notamment par la justice de son pays
ryad dénonce aujourd'hui toutes ces
accusations
le gouvernement d'arabie saoudite ce
projet totalement les conclusions
fausses et préjudiciables contenues dans
le rapport concernant la direction du
royaume et ne peut les accepter en aucun
cas voici le donne annoncé des sanctions
financières contre le général à la syrie
ainsi que plusieurs membres chargés de
la protection du prince mohammed bin
salman 76 personnes saoudienne soupçonné
d'avoir participé à des menaces contre
des dissidents ou journalistes à
l'étranger sont désormais interdit de
séjour aux états unis le prince héritier
lui n'est pas concerné par ces mesures
restrictives je dirais que la relation
avec l'arabie saoudite est importante
nous avons d'importants intérêts en
cours nous restons engagés dans la
défense du royaume mais nous voulons
également nous assurer et c'est ce que
le président a dit dès le début que la
relation reflète mieux nos intérêts et
nos valeurs et donc ce que nous avons
fait par les actions que nous avons
entreprises n'est pas vraiment de rompre
la relation mais de l'art calibrer les
oublie
le président américain s'est entretenu
directement jeudi au téléphone avec le
roi selman avant la publication de ce
rapport
l'arabie saoudite a insisté pour que son
partenariat solide avec les états unis
continuent d'exister je cite dans un
respect mutuel